In time-honoured Marvel tradition, Black Panther
includes a couple of cool post-credits scenes
with teases for upcoming films.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here
and today I'm breaking down Black Panther's
end-credits scenes to explain how they set
up Avengers: Infinity War and I'll also be
revealing some Marvel easter eggs you might
have missed.
If this is your first time here, I do regular
videos on Marvel movies and I'm also starting
my Black Panther Funko Pop giveaway!
For a chance to win, you just need to be a
subscriber and leave me a comment below with
your thoughts about the film.
Quick spoiler warning, I will be discussing
the end credit scenes in full, explaining
their link to the rest of the movie as well
as talking connections to and potential speculation
on Avengers: Infinity War.
The mid-credits scene begins with T'Challa
attending the UN in Vienna and delivering
a speech to the international community.
In the speech, T'Challa announces that, for
the first time in his country's history, he's
opening up Wakanda to the world and offers
to share their knowledge and resources.
Wakanda has, up until now, isolated itself,
using its technology to hide its precious
vibranium resources "in plain sight", but
at the UN, T'Challa implies that it's no longer
right for Wakanda or any country to hide itself
way.
In fact, he wants Wakanda to be an example
of how we should all treat each other, and
as he says, "in times of crisis, the wise
build bridges while the foolish build barriers".
In response, one of the UN delegates asks
what Wakanda can offer the rest of the world,
because in his eyes it's just a "nation of
farmers".
The scene stops at this point, with Black
Panther, Nakia, and Everett Ross all smiling
knowingly at the utter foolishness of that
question – and Ross perhaps recognises too
just how wrong he was earlier in the film
when he shared that delegate's attitude.
Still, we can assume that T'Challa would go
on to reveal that Wakanda has reserves of
vibranium and has developed technology and
medical treatments beyond what is available
anywhere else in the world.
By taking this step, T'Challa has acted on
Nakia's very real concern that during her
time as a Wakandan spy abroad she has "seen
too many in need to turn a blind eye."
It's clear from the film that opening up access
to Wakandan medical technology, for instance,
has the potential to revolutionise how people
recover from injuries as Everett Ross fully
recovers from being shot in the spine in just
one day after being treated by Shuri.
Access to Wakandan vibranium could be a double-edged
sword as although it will likely be useful
in the fight against Thanos, once the secret's
out, it could attract other villains to try
and get their hands on it, as was the case
with Ulysses Klaue.
And, along with Thanos's search for the still-to-be-uncovered
Soul Stone, that could be another reason why
we see in the Infinity War trailer that the
Mad Titan has sent his Outriders to invade
the country.
But this opening up of Wakanda also has huge
implications beyond Avengers: Infinity War
as it means we're likely to see future Marvel
movies cross over with Black Panther and Wakanda.
The world, characters, and tech of Wakanda
are so rich and ripe with opportunities for
storytelling that it seems likely that Marvel
will want to incorporate Black Panther's world
wherever it fits.
The mid-credits scene is also a call-back
to the UN Sokovia Accords meeting in Vienna
in Captain America: Civil War where T'Challa's
father, King T'Chaka, addressed the UN and
attempted to make a similar speech offering
Wakandan co-operation and outreach to the
wider world.
T'Chaka was, of course, killed before he could
finish his speech when Zemo orchestrated an
attack on the UN building in order to frame
Bucky.
And this takes us to Black Panther's second
and final post-credits scene that has an even
more direct lead-in to Avengers: Infinity
War.
In this scene, we find someone waking up in
a small hut in the Wakandan countryside surrounded
by some inquisitive children.
As the person steps outside, we discover it's
Bucky, who we last saw being put on ice in
the mid-credits scene for Captain America:
Civil War.
Bucky agreed to be put under so that Wakandan
scientists could figure out what was wrong
with his mind, and in the Avengers: Infinity
War prelude comic, we learn that it's Shuri
who's figured out how to remove trigger words
that HYDRA inserted in Bucky's mental programming.
Shuri's treatment appears to have worked as
Bucky seems calm and well.
He's also wearing a blue sling around his
missing arm in the scene and at the end Shuri
tells him to come with her as there is "much
more for [him] to learn", which likely means
they need to update him on what's been happening
since he was in cryo-stasis and get him back
in full shape.
We know from the Avengers: Infinity War trailer
that Bucky has his missing arm restored at
some point, so Shuri probably still has some
more work to do on that and perhaps it'll
be made of vibranium too.
There's also a big hint to what Bucky's role
might be next in the name "White Wolf" which
the children in the scene call out as they
run off.
"White Wolf" is an interesting Marvel easter
egg and a nod to the Black Panther comic-book
character Hunter who was adopted by T'Challa's
father T'Chaka when his parents crash-landed
in Wakanda.
The white foreigner, Hunter, aka White Wolf,
loved his adoptive country and eventually
became head of the secret police in Wakanda.
So, in this post-credits scene Marvel could
be alluding to the MCU's Bucky taking on a
similar type of security role in Wakanda in
the future.
Indeed, in the Avengers: Infinity War trailer,
Bucky looks like he might be heading up a
group of Wakandan warriors on the battlefield.
And given his past activities, it would be
a natural fit for Bucky to take on black ops-style
missions on behalf of Black Panther.
Wakanda already operates a network of spies,
or War Dogs as they're called, and perhaps
Bucky could join them, maybe teaming up with
Nakia on future missions.
It'll be interesting to see if Bucky does
take on the new identity of White Wolf, leaving
behind his former alter ego of the Winter
Soldier, or whether this is just simply a
nice nod to the comics.
By the way, given the importance of Shuri's
tech genius, I want to point out another way
in which this could link in to the next Avengers
team-up.
We know that Thanos pursues Vision in the
Infinity War movie and that the Mad Titan's
Black Order are seen either attempting to
extract or manipulate the Mind Stone in Vision's
forehead.
And it's been rumoured that Vision gets taken
to Wakanda in the film so Shuri can extract
the Mind Stone from him and keep it safe.
In the Avengers: Infinity War prelude comic
Shuri boasts that the tech she's developed
surpasses anything Tony Stark has done, specifically
how Stark created Ultron, which seems like
another big hint that Shuri could be involved
in removing the Mind Stone from Vision and
keeping him alive at the same time.
Now, if you've seen Black Panther, what did
you think of the movie and the post-credit
scenes?
And have you got any theories on what the
end credits will mean for Avengers: Infinity
War or future Marvel movies?
Share your thoughts in the comments below
and also make sure you're subscribed to enter
my Black Panther giveaway.
And if you enjoyed this, you can support my
channel by hitting the thumbs-up button and
sharing the video.
I really appreciate all you do and I've got
more Black Panther and Avengers videos coming
shortly, so why not hit the bell and join
the notification squad?!
In the meantime, there's more Marvel and other
videos you're sure to like right here.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!